We're now going to take a look at some ways to optimize our materials. And the first optimization
we're going to talk about isn't an optimization for performance, but it is an optimization for your workflow.
And that's the concept of parent materials. Now,
for those of you who are not aware, parent materials are a way to have
something pass traits on down to their children. Kind of like how in a biological family
parents pass traits on down to the children.
So here we have the squares, and they have the ability to be blue, red, or green.
And we can see here that the squares have some children, and the children have the ability to be red, green, or blue.
Now again, very, very simplistic look at how parents pass traits on down to their children.
But if we take that and we kind of apply it to our material system, we can get something like this.
We have this mat ENVy building parent, and then from that we have these children that were made that were
adjusted, and we have one that looks exactly the same, one that looks slightly different, and one that looks completely different.
We also have this mat ENVy glass parent, and similar, we have one that looks
totally different.
Throughout all of these, actually all the glass ones look completely different than their parent material, and that's okay.
A couple of the reasons why we have it set up like this. One,
since glass is a special material that we're going to be using in special instances,
and it also can be very expensive to render, we want to make sure that we have a parent material that's dedicated for that,
so that we only use that in those limited areas.
This mat ENVy building parent, we're going to use that probably all over, so we want to make sure that
this material that we create is as optimized as possible because it's going to be used all over the place.
Now, a couple of things to note here.
When you are creating materials, you should, or I
recommend that you disable the automatically set usage flags in the editor option.
The reason for this is it will help save on compile times should somebody accidentally put a material on something that it wasn't
necessarily intended for. For example,
sometimes you might find that the landscape material has use with Niagara mesh on it.
The other thing is that we want to keep our materials as modular as possible to minimize
permutations, and we want to optimize for usage, not convenience. So we want to make sure that our materials
only contain things that we intend to use with them and
not contain things that maybe we might possibly turn on, we're not really sure.
The feature quality switch expression nodes
allow you to
ensure that whatever materials you're creating will behave correctly on a platform that might not necessarily
support a certain feature.
For these nodes, we have a shading path, feature level, and quality level.
And basically what we do is we add these to whatever inputs such as base color or normal or roughness or metallic,
and then we feed in
what will happen when this material is, say, viewed on the default, deferred,
forward, or mobile shading paths, or if it detects that the feature level is default
ES2, ES3, SM5, or SM6, or
the quality of the project has been changed from default, low, high, medium, and epic.
Some important notes about these,
just like with other static switches, these generate additional shader permutations for every possible combination of settings. For example, if we have
two static switch parameters, or I should say
two quality switches, it's going to create a possible combination of
four,
but it's only going to use the combinations that are used in our materials. So just keep that in mind.
We want to make sure that we are using these in situations where we know some type of effect or some type of advanced
material logic is not going to work on one of our target platforms,
so it is okay for us to pay that additional cost to make sure that the material compiles correctly.
So to wrap things up, we want to use shader path switches for render path specific logic. We want to use feature level
switches for cross-platform materials and
quality switches for scalable performance. We always want to make sure that to monitor permutation counts as every combination of
these nodes will have some type of cost.